[Musica]
nel 2017 ad un Ted organizzato
dall'università Politecnica della
California Michael cellenberger ha
provato a chiedersi da dove nasce la
paura del nucleare e lo ha raccontato
spiegando Come si sia diffusa nei
movimenti ambientalisti negli anni 60 e
70 con l'aiuto di qualche Contributo
economico da parte delle compagnie
petrolifere
oggi la domanda che ci facciamo invece
come si mantiene Viva la paura
dell'energia nucleare E questa domanda
Ha una risposta complessa sicuramente
parte del problema e il fatto che il
nucleare è una tecnologia sconosciuta ai
più che richiede competenze tecniche
sebbene razionalmente sappiamo che i
combustibili fossili uccidono milioni di
persone soprattutto il carbone tutto
sommato li conosciamo sono il diavolo
che conosciamo e quindi ce li facciamo
quasi andare meglio
questo è tutto vero ma forse qualche
responsabilità andrebbe a scritta anche
al giornalismo alla stampa
nel 2011 l'undici marzo il Giappone come
sappiamo è stato colpito da un terremoto
particolarmente violento magnitudo 9
30.000 volte più potente di quello che
ha Raso al suolo L'Aquila al terremoto è
seguito uno Tsunami che ha provocato
un'onda di 15 metri la combinazione di
questi due eventi ha provocato 15.500
morti 3.500 dispersi e qualche
inconveniente all'impianto nucleare di
Fukushima da ichi dove si sono Fusi i
noccioli di tre reattori e un quarto
reattore ha avuto problemi alla piscina
del combustibile esausto che ha diffuso
una moderata quantità di radiazioni in
atmosfera le conseguenze di questo
incidente sono state studiate dall che
il comitato scientifico delle Nazioni
Unite sugli effetti delle radiazioni
atomiche un comitato che mette insieme
esperti di livello mondiale di Radio
chimica patologia molecolare ingegneria
nucleare e quant'altro le conseguenze a
cui è arrivato questo comitato sono
state pubblicate in questo report del
2013 e vediamo cosa ci dicono
non sono stati osservate morti o
malattia acute dovute alle radiazioni
tra i lavoratori tra la popolazione
generale esposta alle radiazioni
dell'incidente le dosi alla popolazione
generale sia quelle ricevute durante il
primo anno sia quelle stimate per
nell'arco della vita sono generalmente
basso e molto basse non ci si aspetta un
indistinguibile aumento dell'incidenza
di effetti sulla salute correlati alle
radiazioni tra i membri esposti della
popolazione generale o tra i loro
discendenti le principali conseguenze
sulla salute sono sul benessere mentale
e sociale quindi insomma una gran paura
ma per fortuna è andato tutto bene
solo che i toni con cui queste notizie
sono state riportate Dai giornali
italiani non sono esattamente gli stessi
la tragedia di Fukushima e l'apocalisse
questo e fan page che cita Il
commissario europeo ettinger che però ha
usato il termine Apocalisse parlando
dello tsunami non dell'incidente
nucleare
poi abbiamo questo articolo Tokyo
capitali in agonia qui non vivremo più
la domanda non è più quando Tokyo
tornerà il business alla quotidiana con
i quotidianità smarrita Ma se ciò
risulterà possibile c'è un fattore
Olimpiadi quest'anno un gruppo di ex
partner residenti in Giappone ha
nominato questo articolo di Repubblica
il peggior articolo giornalistico
sull'incidente di Fukushima scritto nel
mondo e vi garantisco che la
competizione era elevata
D'altra parte lo stesso inviato
Giampaolo visetti ha pubblicato anche
questo articolo la lotta dei
sopravvissuti sette giorni dopo
l'apocalisse dove racconta la storia di
questo operaio che diciamo si sacrifica
per riparare il reattore 4 pur non
conoscendolo perché anziano e vuole
salvare la vita ai suoi colleghi che
vanno in pensione il nome è futoshi toba
voi Provate a googlare questo nome
scoprite che futòshi toba era il sindaco
di un paese che si chiama Enrico
sindacata che è stato distrutto dallo
tsunami la storia di Giampaolo visetti è
completamente inventata Anche perché la
Apple non ha mai fornito i nomi dei
liquidatori e nessuno di essi è morto
l'incidente di Fukushima ha continuato
negli anni a dare soddisfazioni perché
i reattori Fusi sono stati raffreddati
con dell'acqua marina che poi deve
essere sversata in mare il piano di
sversamento dell'acqua marina è stato
approvato dall'agenzia internazionale
dell'energia atomica un organo delle
Nazioni Unite che dice questo
il Trizio che è l'unico elemento
radioattivo che sopravvive al filtraggio
fatto con il sistema alps Advance Liquid
Processing System il Trizio sarà diluito
fino ad un livello di 1.500 Baker litro
che è un quarantesimo della
concentrazione permessa dagli standard
di sicurezza giapponesi e un settimo di
quello che ehm guarda dentro
organizzation loms Considera la linea
guida per l'acqua potabile quindi
l'acqua che sarà versata di Fukushima e
7 volte meno radioattiva di quella che
non l'ho messo Considera che si possa
bere
In effetti l'ammontare totale di Trizio
che viene scaricato sarà sotto i target
per operational target operativi della
centrale prima dell'incidente cioè
l'acqua è radioattiva che l'acqua che
sarà scaricata in mare sarà meno
radioattiva di quella che la centrale
scaricava prima dell'incidente
per capire meglio questa cosa da un
punto di vista anche scientifico
possiamo vedere il fattore di
conversione tra beckerel e millisi
silverty beckerelli indicano l'attività
di un radionuclide i missili il
potenziale danno biologico vediamo che
per l'acqua triziata il valore è questo
0,0000018
millisiber per chi lo Becker quindi
1.500 perché era il per litro sono 1,5
kg Quindi
0,00000
se noi bevessimo un litro di acqua di
Fukushima tutti i giorni per un anno
accumuleremo una dose di 0,01
millisivert e tanto poco
ce lo dice quanti dice quant'è la Health
physic Society che ci dice sotto ad un
livello di 100 millisive sopra la
radiazione di fondo da tutte le fonti
combinate l'effetto delle radiazioni
sulle persone non è statisticamente
distinguibile da zero
sotto i 100 nelle distribuire a zero noi
siamo a 0,01 un litro d'acqua di
Fukushima vediamo com'è andato la
notizia giornali italiani
Ecco dove potrebbe finire l'acqua
contaminata con quali rischi per
l'Oceano mappa dell'oceano che diventa
rosso
poi sotto bontà loro riportano
l'opinione dell'esperto la sua
concentrazione sarà tale da non
danneggiare le coste
fa di meglio quotidiano nazionale
l'acqua contaminata di Fukushima
danneggia il DNA umano
e poi il mio preferito ovviamente il
manifesto dilaga la pandemia nucleare
questo titolo non significa
assolutamente nulla
ma mette insieme due parole che fanno
paura e soprattutto è uscito nel 2021
durante una pandemia e quindi questo
titolo viene indicizzato molto bene da
Google
andiamo a un fatto più recente
il 24 febbraio la Russia invaso
l'Ucraina il 4 marzo ci sono stati
scontri Nella notte tra il 3 e il 4
marzo ci sono stati i primi scontri nei
pressi dell'impianto nucleare di zaporiz
durante questi scontri
è stato colpito un edificio
amministrativo che ha preso fuoco
nessuno dei reattori è stato toccato se
fosse successo comunque si tratta di
reattori moderni con sistemi di
protezione molto avanzati contenuti in
edifici di contenimento molto resistenti
il giorno dopo quindi già il 4 marzo
l'agenzia internazionale dell'energia
atomica pubblicava questo statement
spiegando Qual era la situazione
la centrale nucleare continua ad essere
operata dal suo staff regolare e non c'è
stato alcun rilascio di materiale
radioattivo i sistemi di sicurezza dei 6
reattori della centrale non sono stati
coinvolti e non c'è stato il rilascio di
materiale radioattivo i sistemi di
monitoraggio della radioattività nel
luogo sono perfettamente funzionali
funzionanti
questo il 4 marzo il 5 marzo Gramellini
ieri al mio risveglio ho scoperto il
nostro sito e ho scoperto che avrei
potuto non risvegliarmi mai più
e poi continua su cosa ne sarebbe stato
di noi preferisco non approfondire Ma le
dimensioni della centrale e il suo nome
zaporizia con tutte quelle Z da ultimo
giorno dell'umanità non autorizzano
pensieri Allegri
e un peccato che abbia deciso di non
approfondire perché se avesse
approfondito avrebbe scoperto che il
giorno prima gli scienziati dell'America
Nuclear Society avevano pubblicato su
Nature una stima delle possibili
conseguenze del dell'incidente degli
scontri alla centralizzaz dicendo un
danno catastrofico da un colpo
accidentale e improbabile se un missile
va a fuori i bersaglio sono molto non
sono molto preoccupato di questo perché
le strutture di contenimento sono molto
robuste molti specialisti hanno detto
Nature che persino se un nocciolo di un
reattore dovesse fondersi non causerebbe
una grossa rilascio di materiale
radioattivo il principale impatto di una
crisi simile sarebbe collegato alla
psicologia e a come le persone incluse i
politici e Policy Makers reagiscono
e ha ragione perché le reazioni dei
politici possono fare più danno delle
radiazioni a Fukushima non sarebbe stato
necessario evacuare le persone le
radiazioni sono basso molto basse come
abbiamo letto prima ma sono state
evacuate 100.000 persone e 500 sono
morte a causa dello stress a causa del
fatto che hanno portato via persone
dagli ospedali in fretta e furia a causa
del fatto che alcuni si sono Suicidati
in preda al panico
in generale quando si parla di
radiazioni molto raro che un giornale
specifico che si tratta di un fenomeno
naturale che in un corpo umano avvengono
in media 8000 decadimenti radioattivi al
secondo dovuti soprattutto al potassio
40 il carbonio 14
i pericoli delle radiazioni vengono
costantemente esagerati quelli di tutto
il resto minimizzati questa Emma Bonino
Nel 1987 che manifesta contro il
nucleare tenendo in mano un carciofo
allo iodio radioattivo di Chernobyl
in questa foto il ma Bonino sta tenendo
effettivamente in mano qualcosa che
uccide ogni anno milioni di persone in
tutto il mondo solo che nell'altra mano
è una sigaretta
e non solo la sigaretta è anche più
radioattiva del Carciofo perché lo iodio
radioattivo si dimezza in 8 giorni
Quindi se quel carciofo fosse stato
davvero contaminato da Chernobyl un anno
dopo sarebbe stato assolutamente non
radioattivo le sigarette invece
contengono Tra le altre cose polonio 210
che è presente in un fertilizzante che
si utilizza nelle piantagioni di tabacco
e così arriviamo a quella che è la
storia principale che Volevo raccontarvi
che è accaduta nel 2001 in un paesino in
Puglia che si chiama San Foca
a San Foca qualcuno prese dei barattoli
di pomodori pelati probabilmente o
qualcosa del genere e ci dipinse Dopo
aver tolto l'etichetta ci dipinse sopra
il simbolo del pericolo radioattivo
vediamo come venne trattata la vicenda
fusti radioattivi in mare allarme San
Foca
tre fusti radio fustini radioattivi
nelle acque di San Foca intanto Torre
Lapillo un giovane rischiato di annegare
le gioie della cronaca locale Allora qua
Questo articolo ve lo riporto nel
dettaglio perché merita
Allora qui abbiamo i carabinieri Hanno
accertato che si trattava effettivamente
di contenitori contenenti materiale
radioattivo destinato a Tunisi per lo
stoccaggio
che hanno già trovato che il materiale
radioattivo e hanno trovato la
destinazione tenete la mente questo
poi abbiamo
finalmente
i tre fustini sono stati radiografati al
fine di verificare la presenza di
radioattività ma dieci righe prima hai
detto che erano radioattivi
la presenza ha coinciso con numerose
segnalazioni di villeggianti circa la
presenza di alcuni strani ciuffetti di
alghe che avrebbero causato bruciore
agli occhi dei bagnanti notoriamente
senza le radiazioni fare il bagno in
mare non ha mai causato bruciore agli
occhi di nessuno
la bella giornata di sole e mare calmo
però coinciso con un decesso sotto
l'ombrellone un salvataggio in estremis
e un brutto incidente stradale questo è
tutto nello stesso articolo
barattoli radioattivi allarme a San Foca
bloccato il porto ma la ASL esclude ogni
rischio ovviamente a un certo punto
qualcuno fa delle indagini diciamo
Questi non sono radioattivi
notate qua la foto eroica vedete sono
barattoli barattoli di conserva la foto
eroica del Carabiniere che le tiene in
mano L'Antico vaso andava portato in
salvo
attenzione dal mare tre barattoli di
scorie radioattive non sono più solo
radioattivi contengono addirittura
scorie cioè combustibile esausto delle
centrali nucleari le scorie normalmente
vengono messe nei canister si chiamano
dry storage caschi o sono larghi un
metro e mezzo al di quattro sono
studiati per resistere inondazioni
terremoti esplosioni corrosioni
impatti di aerei o treni ci fanno
proprio i crash test lanciando gli treni
gli aerei contro Qua invece le mettiamo
nei barattolini
notate qua
l'ASL esclusa ogni contaminazione questo
nel trafiletto in piccolo
però scorie radioattive nel porto il
fatto che siano radioattivo lo scriviamo
in gigantografia il fatto che non siano
radioattive cioè escluso ogni
contaminazione in piccolo in alto
l'ex fidanzata che ama i Carabinieri e
lui ripicchia questo è di nuovo sono le
sono le gioie della cronaca locale
probabilmente c'entrano le radiazioni
anche qua
poi iniziano le teorie del complotto
Maria di pesci e ricci che si sgretolano
gli esperti minimizzano colpa di un
microrganismo notate barattoli vuoti
nessun rischio Ma la gente ha paura
nell'acqua c'è davvero qualcosa di
strano
Si stimola il panico una volta che tu
dici alle persone che le radiazioni sono
pericolose ci fai vedere un barattolino
col simbolo della radioattività
l'effetto placebo fa il resto sono tutti
convinti di essere
contaminati che ci sia qualcosa di
strano
E infatti in fila dal medico
pruriti sul corpo arrossamento degli
occhi patologie normali che ora fanno
paura non so se siete andati in spiaggia
al mare l'arrossamento degli occhi se
fate il bagno nell'acqua salata è una
cosa normale ma la gente infila dal
medico che potrebbe far ridere ma magari
c'era qualcuno che davvero aveva bisogno
di andare dal medico
decine di bagnanti al pronto soccorso
San Foca tutti in fila al pronto
soccorso medicinali esaurito in poche
ore ma magari quei medicinali servivano
a qualcuno magari quei medicinali non
andavano presi
sempre durante la crisi Ucraina sia in
Italia sia in Belgio si è verificato il
fenomeno dell'assalto alle farmacie per
l'acquisto di pastiglie di iodio per
proteggersi da un Fallout ma abbiamo
letto prima quel Fallout non succede se
succede a 2000 km non c'è nessun
pericolo per gli italiani in compenso le
pastiglie di odio hanno effetti
collaterali non andrebbero mai prese
senza prescrizione medica possono
provocare ipertiroidismo addirittura
tumore papillare della tiroide la gente
si sta letteralmente facendo del male
per prevenire un pericolo inesistente
poi abbiamo la nave sospetta avvistata
al largo alla fine dello scorso mese una
nave battente bandiera italiana forse
proveniente da Venezia e diretta in
Tunisia a quanto pare
la Lega Navale ha segnalato alla locale
capitaneria di porto che quel natante
stava probabilmente scaricando qualcosa
in mare i controlli dell'acqua non
avrebbero dimostrato la presenza di
alcuna sostanza inquinante Tuttavia i
fatti verificati si hanno fatto venire
in mente la nave sospetta
barattoli radioattivi potrebbe anche
trattarsi di uno scherzo questo è lo
stesso giornale che aveva scritto che
erano diretti a Tunisi
erano sicurissimi il primo giorno
diretti a Tunisi scorie radioattiva
abbiamo trovato un aspetto uno scherzo
Tuttavia per accertare questo
eventualità il magistrato ha disposto il
trasferimento in un centro specializzato
non ci bastano le indagini dell'ASL
mandiamo a Roma questi
e allarme la procura Indaga qua di nuovo
abbiamo la foto dell'eroe con L'Antico
vaso San Foca la parola Roma noi 20
amici finiti a letto con la febbre Dopo
la mattina al mare
dermatiti e congiuntiviti fra i bagnanti
come coincidenze davvero strana la
congiuntivite quando sta in spiaggia a
guardare il sole non è mai venuta
nessuno sono sicuramente le radiazioni
e poi il complottista da settimane
sostengo che qui c'è qualcosa di strano
che questo tratto di mare presenta un
inquinamento particolare e molto
preoccupante Ora molti me ne devono dare
atto il mitomane di turno
e finalmente gli esperti barattoli
recuperati a San Foca non sono
radioattivi però hanno tutti titolato
barattoli radioattivi a San focarone che
hanno aspettato di verificare Ora vorrei
concludere questo intervento con una
citazione
di un grandissimo stand up comedian e
quindi vorrei dirvi che lo scopo di
questo intervento Ovviamente non è
quello di legittimare il giornalismo
italiano mio scopo è farvi riflettere
sulla differenza tra pericolo reale e
percepito quando si parla di
radioattività non voglio certo dire che
i giornalisti italiani sono spesso
irresponsabili che farebbero qualunque
cosa per due click in più e incluso
demonizzare tecnologie che potrebbero
salvare milioni di vite non è
assolutamente quello che voglio dire
bat Maybe
Grazie a tutti
[Applauso]
[Musica]